this beautiful morning i i missed two of
her face time calls
and i called her back and i i said diana
where are you
she's like oh me and josie were going to
go to the lake and
i was going to have them fish nya
rivera's mother and sister
reflect on her life and legacy one year
after her death
i go well the water's getting choppy and
i said i love you
and call me call me when you get off the
water
the glee star's mom yolanda and sister
nikayla
opened up about the late actress during
an interview with good morning america
on thursday
exactly one year after the 33 year old
was first reported
missing following a boat ride with her
son josie on lake pairu
in ventura county california those first
five days were
hell awful hell on earth hell on earth
my
faith told me that
nothing is missing surely not a person
yes we we just can't find them so that
was my
my thing god you know where she's at
just bring her back to us yolanda
recalled her final conversation with nya
while she was
out on the rental boat with a then
four-year-old josie
and said the screenshots she took during
their facetime call
helped lead the search and rescue team
to her grandson
he said don't worry we have josie but
your daughter's missing and it was
almost like a force
i don't know what it was but i literally
i was just
pushed backwards just screaming
nia was found and pronounced dead five
days later on july
13th there are a lot of currents on the
lake
the idea perhaps being that the boat
started drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself and when
eti sat down with nya's father george
in june he opened up about his
daughter's final heroic act
well sort of the same mantra she used
for life you know preservation
keep going when things are hard you keep
pushing
right it just shows you the strength of
the person following her sister's death
nikayla moved in with josie and his
father ryan dorsey
i knew right when it happened and right
when we got him
i knew the role that i had to take it's
so reminiscent because
he's like a boy version of her in
every sense of the word in what way his
tenacity his drive
his zeal his adventure for life
he's just he's he's naya in boyform
he loves entertaining yes he loves
singing
at the top of his being a mom was
always priority number one for nya
something she talked to et about
in 2016. what's next for you you know
i'm a mom now
and i you know what i love more than
acting is being josie's mom
so i want to be here for him and i don't
want to miss anything
and nya's dad told et how his daughter
changed for the better after becoming a
mother
he really became everything for her
right her focus
her focus was really on on him
and as he was
growing up as she was becoming a mother
she she really leaned into that
the word i want to use is maturity
became very mature as a person
and and really receptive to other
people's feelings
nya's ex taj maurie who dated the
actress on and off during the early
2000's
echoed all that during a chat with e.t
in may
i think overall the the amazing mother
that she became
um and and the working mother that she
became i think she's
the the spitting image of
what women are capable of doing just as
capable as
best men are you know what i mean and
she was so strong
she was hilarious oh my god
and so talented so talented her voice
always was the best i had ever heard
naya's mom and sister also spoke to her
legacy
including her impact playing the
groundbreaking role of santana lopez
a queer latina on glee
[Music]
me
[Music]
people would come up to her all the time
and say you saved my life
my sister was touching people's
real lives and helping them become
who they really are and not being
ashamed of that
i would like my daughters nya's legacy
to be one that
teaches people to love
love who you are because you don't get
another life
you